let's go to our voicemail two one nine
two david p is the voicemail number
jimmy from philly is wondering why I
didn't cover a particular story about
Bernie Sanders take a listen to this
David give me some celery
yeah why have we not seen you drop a
video on the women that took Barney's
mic once again topless why have we not
seen you show how weak Bernie Sanders
actually is uh-huh I mean this man is
that black lives matter people grab his
mic right now it's well white college
girls pitiless grab his mic what more do
you need to see David to figure out that
you voted for a little [ __ ] alright
like I understand yeah so listen first
of all the entire why don't you grab the
mic back thing is a double-edged sword
because if Bernie doesn't take the mic
back when the mic has been grabbed and I
don't think that the topless protesters
did that if you don't take the mic back
people like Jimmy from Philly say it's
bata behavior if you do grab the mic
back cynical actors will say that it was
almost a physical attack on women and
what is Bernie doing as a man taking the
microphone back so I actually understand
why Bernie just walks away when the
protesters come on stage we just don't
cover protests in this way like Biden's
been protested Bernie's been Prost at it
this is not what do you want me to say
about it okay yeah Bernie was protested
by topless protesters what's the story
that that's why we haven't covered it
Jimmy we've got a great bonus show for
you today I hope you will join us there
become a member or a patron to get
yourself instant access